[Applause]
[Music]
20:18 is off to a great start and now
that we're bordering on February it's
time for another month wide episode of
new releases except for one last January
game but trust me it's a big one so
we'll hit that first because it's the
city of Final Fantasy and T if you ever
wanted to actually play out the
action-packed fights usually reserved
for JRPG cutscenes this is your chance
NT has heroes and villains from all the
numbered Final Fantasy games even type-0
and tactics you can bring a trio of
characters into each battle and even
call on classic Final Fantasy summons
for help NT has been in Japanese arcades
for a bit but you can finally assemble
your team on ps4 in the West on Tuesday
January 30th I know which fun-loving
blonde I'm choosing and with that we can
make a clean break into February with
Shadow of the Colossus if you missed out
on this giant slang adventure back on
ps2 or the remaster on ps3 for that
matter then this is your chance to play
the Ari remaster remake is probably a
better word though since this one has
been rebuilt from the ground up for ps4
but you'll still have to conquer all the
massive colossi with your sword and bow
like before learning why the beasts were
awoken in the first place that's
happening on Tuesday February 6th but if
you want to see it in action before that
we've got to look at some early battles
and the remakes new filter options on
GameSpot maybe you don't want to fight
big monsters maybe you want to fight a
bunch of troops that are more your size
enter dynasty Warriors 9 the latest
entry in the series still has the hack
and slash combat you expect but now it's
paired with an explorable open-world you
can traverse China at your own pace
coming across enemy Garrison's and
initiating those massive battles when
you pleased with day/night and dynamic
weather cycles affecting your strategies
the battle begins on ps4 Xbox one and PC
on Tuesday the 13th if you'd rather
fight as a witch than Chinese historical
figures than the Bayonetta series is for
you and now one and two are coming to
Nintendo switch if you missed out on
them the first time here's the elevator
pitch it's a beat'em up with stylish
action a lot like Devil May Cry but with
guns on your feet also Bayonetta can
turn her hair into monsters and execute
her enemies
it's pretty rad Boneta 3 is also headed
to switch in the future but one in two
kicked things off on Friday the 16th and
finally we have to talk about what is
weirdly one of the most anticipated
games of the year
Metal Gear survive is the first game in
the series sense8 a Okajima departure
from Konami and it looks to be a very
different experience from snake sneaking
missions it's an open world survival
game where you'll have to scavenge for
resources to build weapons and defenses
you can tackle the challenge solo or
with friends on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
the 20th and those are some of the
hottest games we'll be playing all month
long as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with your
regular dose of new releases next Sunday